.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Melancholische Streichmusik *
* Die Musik verklingt. *
Luigi Fragale kehrt zurück
an den Ort seiner Kindheit.
Eine Kindheit geprägt
von Entbehrungen und Angst.
Wenn du von klein auf
mit Angst lebst ...
Wenn ein Kind von fünf
oder sechs Jahren Angst haben muss,
wenn es sich verletzt,
wenn es das Haus verlässt,
wenn jemand an der Tür klingelt
oder wenn es zu viel Lärm macht ...
Bei allem, was man tut,
hat man Angst.
Und in dem Alter versteht man nicht,
weshalb das eigene Verhalten
falsch ist.
Man fragt sich ständig:
"Darf ich das jetzt tun?"
Bellach bei Solothurn.
Hierhin zog Luigis Vater
in den 1970er-Jahren aus Kalabrien,
nachdem er eine Saisonstelle
auf dem Bau gefunden hatte.
Zunächst lebte er alleine hier,
später folgte ihm seine Frau,
dann kamen auch Luigi
und sein jüngerer Bruder -
heimlich,
denn die Schweiz verbot Saisonniers
damals den Familiennachzug.
Zweieinhalb Jahre lebten Mutter
und Kinder fortan im Versteckten,
ohne Aufenthaltsbewilligung
und ohne Krankenkasse.
Nur ganz selten
durften sie nach draussen,
aus Angst,
von Nachbarn entdeckt zu werden.
Manchmal durften wir bei
schönem Wetter mit unserer Mutter
nach draussen
und auf dem Rasen dort spielen.
Und einmal, als es geschneit hatte -
das werde ich nie vergessen -,
durften wir dort hinter
den Gebüschen links spielen.
Dort hatte es viel Schnee
und wir durften dort spielen.
Aber nicht lange,
maximal eine halbe Stunde.
Wir durften uns nicht verletzen,
mit niemandem sprechen ...
Das war unser Leben.
Unsere Wohnung
lag im obersten Stock.
Es gab Schimmel in der Wohnung.
Ein grauer, monotoner Alltag,
bei dem einzig
der Blick nach draussen
etwas Abwechslung brachte.
Hier waren jeweils die Enten.
Mit ihnen
verging die Zeit etwas schneller.
Wir haben die Enten
aus dem Fenster beobachtet.
Damit verbrachten wir
einen grossen Teil unseres Alltags.
Luigis Eltern versuchten,
ihm zu erklären,
warum er nicht draussen spielen
durfte so wie die anderen Kinder.
In Italien
durfte ich draussen spielen.
Ich lebte dort
bei meiner Grossmutter.
Als ich in die Schweiz kam,
dachte ich,
dass es normal sei,
sich verstecken zu müssen.
Doch ich verstand nicht, warum.
Deshalb hatte ich innerlich
einen Hass auf die Schweiz.
Ich fragte mich:
"Warum gibt mir dieses Land
diese Freiheit nicht?"
Also wollte ich zurück nach Italien,
mit der ganzen Familie.
* Traurige Musik *
Mit acht Jahren
konnte Luigi zur Schule.
Die Schulkommission
ermöglichte ihm dies,
auch wenn die Wohngemeinde
nichts von seiner Existenz wusste.
Doch dann stand
die Fremdenpolizei vor der Tür.
Und dann wurden wir
eines Tages verraten.
Wir hatten Nachbarn,
auch Landsleute,
die sich fragten:
"Wie kann diese Familie
ihre Kinder in die Schule schicken
und wir dürfen unsere Kinder
nicht mal in der Schweiz behalten?"
Also haben sie uns verraten.
Und dann
begann der Stress erst richtig.
Dann kam die Fremdenpolizei
und wir hätten die Schweiz
schnellstmöglich
wieder verlassen müssen.
* Sehnsüchtige Musik *
Der Vater wollte mit seiner Familie
zurück nach Italien.
Sein Arbeitgeber hatte dem Ehepaar
jedoch ein Darlehen
für den Kauf
einer Wohnung in Süditalien gewährt,
das noch nicht ganz
zurückbezahlt war.
Zudem war der Vater
ein sehr guter Arbeiter.
Also setzte sich sein Arbeitgeber
für die Familie ein
und sie durfte schliesslich bleiben.
Das war eigentlich unser Glück.
Ohne diese Schulden wären wir heute
wohl nicht in der Schweiz.
* Sehnsüchtige Musik *
Luigi hat seinen Weg gemacht.
Ein Weg, der allerdings steinig war.
Er besuchte die Sonderschule.
* Leises Stimmengewirr *
Männer wie Luigis Vater.
Sie kommen im Frühling
aus dem Süden,
und neun Monate später müssen sie
die Schweiz wieder verlassen.
Saisonarbeiter,
Menschen mit Koffern,
aber ohne Familien.
Auch die Schweizer
packen ihre Koffer.
Das Land, das glückliche,
blieb von den Verheerungen
des Zweiten Weltkriegs verschont.
* Dynamische Musik *
Hochkonjunktur,
der Wohlstand wächst.
Ferienreisen mit dem eigenen Auto
wurden für grosse Teile
der Bevölkerung erschwinglich.
Und neue Autobahnen versprechen,
die Schweizer noch schneller ans
Ziel ihrer Ferienträume zu bringen,
das meist im Süden liegt -
dort, wo die Ausländer herkommen.
* Die Musik verklingt. *
Heute wird die Eröffnung
des San-Bernardino-Tunnels gefeiert.
* Applaus *
Der neue Alpen-Durchstich
bildet nicht nur
einen eindrücklichen Beweis
der Lebenskraft
und des Zukunftsglaubens
des Schweizer Volkes,
er zeugt auch von der wachsenden
Leistungsfähigkeit unseres Landes.
Nicht unerwähnt
darf allerdings bleiben,
dass wir auf die Mitwirkung
zahlreicher ausländischer
Arbeitskräfte angewiesen waren.
Die Fremdarbeiter
mit Aufenthaltsbewilligung
reichen nicht aus,
die neue Schweiz zu bauen.
So holt man Saisonarbeitskräfte.
In den Zeiten der Hochkonjunktur
kommen jährlich
über 200'000 Saisonniers ins Land.
Die meisten von ihnen
werden auf den Baustellen benötigt.
* Dynamische Musik *
Andere im Gastgewerbe.
Mehrheitlich an Arbeitsplätzen,
die Schweizern nicht behagen.
Die Saisonniers, die Puffermasse
des Schweizer Wirtschaftswunders.
Menschen zweiter Klasse.
Sie sollen hier
neun Monate arbeiten,
sich jedoch nicht heimisch fühlen,
sich keinesfalls integrieren.
Kinder sind verboten.
* Musik steigert sich. *
Sind Sie verheiratet?
- Ja.
Wo ist Ihre Frau?
- In Italien.
Kinder?
- Zwei.
Auch in Italien?- Alle. Das Gesetz
erlaubt nicht, dass sie herkommen.
Die Frau ist in Spanien.
Hätten Sie sie gern hier?
Wenn es möglich wäre,
hätte ich sie gern an meiner Seite.
Haben Sie Kinder?
- Vier.
Nicola Colatrella,
gebürtiger Italiener,
betreute für eine Gewerkschaft
Saisonniers in der Zentralschweiz.
Bitter wurde seine Arbeit,
wenn wieder
ein verstecktes Saisonnier-Kind
von der Fremdenpolizei entdeckt
und des Landes verwiesen wurde.
Das war für mich nicht akzeptabel.
Manchmal kamen mir die Tränen,
ich darf es ruhig sagen.
Denn es war hart zu sehen,
wie ein Vater
seine Kinder verabschieden musste.
Zuweilen begleitete ich sie
an den Luzerner Bahnhof,
um dem Vater zur Seite zu stehen.
In Bern lebt und arbeitet die
Psychotherapeutin Marina Frigerio,
eine schweizerisch-italienische
Doppelbürgerin.
Sie kennt die Nöte,
wenn die Saisonniers ihre Kinder
in der Heimat bei Verwandten
zurücklassen mussten.
Für die Kinder
gab es eine Entfremdung.
Und das haben mir
viele Betroffene erzählt:
Sie sehen ihre Eltern
als Onkel und Tante
und nicht als Papi und Mami.
Es fehlte die Vertrautheit.
Plus: Die wichtige Bindung,
die Vertrauenspersonen,
waren nicht
die Mutter und der Vater,
sondern irgendjemand anderes.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Saisonarbeiterinnen
in der Textilindustrie.
Unter ihnen wohl auch Mütter,
die ihre Kinder
in die Schweiz mitnahmen.
Doch diese
blieben unsichtbar im Land.
Wie viele waren es?
Es gibt nur Schätzungen dazu:
15'000 bis 50'000
sollen es zwischen 1950
und den 90er-Jahren gewesen sein.
Versteckte Kinder.
Marina Frigerio
hat einige dieser Biografien
in einem Buch zusammengetragen.
Viele anonym,
denn da ist eine grosse Scham,
über das Erlittene zu sprechen.
Fast alle Eltern
möchten ein guter Vater
und eine gute Mutter sein
und ein gutes Familienleben führen.
Und wenn man das nicht kann,
dann fühlt man,
dass man versagt hat.
Damit umzugehen ist
sehr schmerzhaft, sehr schwierig,
und man versucht,
das Geschehene abzuwenden
oder fernzuhalten,
aber in der Tat
kann so eine Wunde nicht heilen,
bis man
die Geschichte aufgerollt hat
und den Kindern
die Wahrheit erklärt hat.
Die Koffer sind wieder gepackt.
Die Reise geht heimwärts.
Ob sie nächstes Jahr erneut
kommen können, weiss kaum jemand.
So ist es auch eine Reise
ins existenzielle Ungewisse.
Doch da ist auch
eine grosse Wiedersehensfreude.
Ich fahre nach Italien
zu meiner Frau
und zu meinen drei Töchtern.
Meine Frau und die Kinder
habe ich nun seit zehn Monaten
nicht mehr gesehen.
Ich gehe meine Frau
und mein Kind besuchen.
Mein kleiner Sohn ist viereinhalb
Jahre alt und heisst Augusto.
Neun Monate lang habe ich
meine Familie nicht mehr gesehen.
Auch meine Familie
lebt in Sizilien,
meine Frau
und meine 17-jährige Tochter, Enza.
Vor zehn Monaten sah ich
meine Angehörigen zum letzten Mal.
Ich werde auch nächstes Jahr
wieder in die Schweiz kommen,
aber eben wiederum
ohne die Familie.
Ein bisschen Süden mitten in Bern.
Der Treff im Breitenrain-Quartier
lädt zu einem Markt
mit Produkten aus Italien.
* Gefühlvolle italienische Musik *
Für mediterrane Stimmung
sorgt auch Fernando D'Amico,
der zusammen mit seiner Formation
von einer Schwalbe singt,
einer Schwalbe unterwegs mit
einer Liebesbotschaft über das Meer.
* Gefühlvolle italienische Musik *
* Musik läuft leise weiter. *
Fernando D'Amico
wuchs in den 1960er-Jahren
bei seinen Grosseltern
in Apulien auf,
nachdem seine Eltern Arbeit
in der Schweiz gefunden hatten.
Als die Grossmutter erkrankte
und die Eltern Fernando nicht
zu sich nach Bern holen konnten,
brachten sie ihn, achtjährig,
in einem Internat in Domodossola
unter, an der Schweizer Grenze.
Näher bei den Eltern
und doch weit weg von ihnen,
neun lange Jahre.
Du wirst
von einem Tag auf den anderen
mit einer neuen Realität
konfrontiert,
die du nicht kennst,
weg von der Familie.
Du weisst nicht, wer diese
neuen Leute um dich herum sind.
Die Eltern haben dir nur gesagt:
"Du musst für gewisse Zeit
in ein Internat,
weil du nicht bei uns sein kannst."
"Wir gehen dann wieder
zurück nach Italien."
Ich habe sehr gelitten
in den ersten Jahren,
weil mir die Eltern fehlten.
Diejenigen,
die um mich herum waren,
konnten sie nicht ersetzen.
In Domodossola
trifft Fernando auf Edie Salvini,
der mit ihm im Internat war.
Gemeinsam machen sie sich auf
an jenen Ort,
der für ihr Leben prägend war.
* Glockenläuten *
Noch immer
führen Kapuziner das Haus,
längst nicht mehr in Kutten gewandet
wie in den 1950er-Jahren,
als sie das Internat für Buben
italienischer Saisonniers schufen,
die in der Schweiz arbeiteten.
Das ist das Refektorium,
wo wir Buben assen,
Frühstück, Mittag- und Abendessen.
Es war voll, wir waren mehr als 80.
Von den Erziehern von damals
ist er noch da:
Padre Vincenzo, an den sich
Fernando und Eddie gerne erinnern.
Er sei gut zu ihnen gewesen,
auch wenn der Alltag
im Internat streng war.
Ich habe die Buben
immer gern gehabt.
Natürlich gab es unter uns
auch solche, die strenger waren.
Ab und zu setzte es da
eine Ohrfeige ab.
Heute dürfte man
das ja nie mehr tun,
aber damals waren die Methoden
halt noch etwas anders.
Voller Sehnsucht erwartete Fernando
jeweils den Besuch seiner Eltern.
Ich erinnere mich,
dass die Eltern alle fünf,
sechs Wochen zu Besuch kamen.
Und als sie wieder gingen,
zählte ich die Tage,
bis es wieder so weit war.
Es kam nicht selten vor,
dass sie dann
kurz zuvor mitteilten,
sie könnten mich nun
aus dem einen oder anderen Grund
doch nicht besuchen.
Da stürzte jeweils
eine Welt für mich zusammen.
Wenn sie hierherkamen,
dann hatte dies immer zwei Gründe:
Zum einen besuchten sie mich,
zum anderen deckten sie sich mit
Lebensmitteln auf dem Markt ein.
Das alles spielte sich
in wenigen Stunden ab.
Wir gingen Mittagessen, sie machten
danach noch die letzten Einkäufe,
bevor sie um fünf Uhr
wieder zurück nach Bern fuhren.
Fernando blieb zurück,
mit etwas Schokolade
aus der Schweiz.
Das Schokoladenpapier
warf ich nie weg,
sondern versteckte es.
Es war wie ... Wie soll ich sagen?
Durch das Papier
schienen mir die Eltern nahe.
Wenn ich das Papier
jeweils hervorholte,
war es,
als wären sie hier.
In den Strassen Domodossolas
hört Fernando
oft einem Gitarrenspieler zu.
Das Instrument fasziniert ihn.
Er bittet seine Eltern,
ihm eine Gitarre zu kaufen.
Er bringt sich das Spiel selbst bei.
Später in der Schweiz
arbeitet er zunächst als Elektriker
und studiert daneben
am Konservatorium.
Heute unterrichtet er Gitarre
und tritt häufig
mit seiner Formation auf.
* Sanfte Gitarrenmusik
mit italienischem Gesang *
Ich verbrachte Stunden um Stunden
mit meiner Gitarre.
Sie wurde
zu einer treuen Begleiterin,
die mir das ersetzte,
was mir damals fehlte.
Die Gitarre wurde Teil von mir,
und sie ist es bis heute geblieben.
Nun, was soll ich sagen:
Das war rassistisch.
Etwas, das heute unvorstellbar ist.
Und doch haben wir
aktuell eine Situation,
die mit damals vergleichbar ist.
Zurzeit beherbergen
wir hier Ukrainerinnen,
Mütter mit ihren Kindern,
38 an der Zahl.
Unser Haus ist voll.
Die Geschichte wiederholt sich,
vor dem Hintergrund anderer
Ereignisse, traurige Ereignisse.
Hoffen wir,
dass sie bald vorbei sind.
* Sehnsüchtige Musik *
Seit bald 40 Jahren
arbeitet und lebt Fernando
zusammen mit seiner Familie
in der Schweiz.
Er habe sich mit
der Vergangenheit versöhnt, sagt er.
Und doch ist nicht vergessen,
dass das Land,
wo seine Kinder geboren sind,
ihn damals nicht wollte.
Einen roten Pass mit weissem Kreuz
hat er nicht.
Nein, ich bin immer noch ...
Nein, ich bin Italiener.
Und das stimmt für mich so.
In Solothurn betreibt Luigi Fragale
seit 17 Jahren einen Coiffeursalon.
Keine Selbstverständlichkeit,
sagt er.
Er, der als Kind zweieinhalb Jahre
im Versteckten leben musste,
Schwierigkeiten in der Schule hatte
und dadurch
keine normale Lehre machen konnte.
Die Eltern ermöglichten ihm
eine Privatschule.
Und dort
konnte ich mich dann etwas öffnen.
Der Beruf gefiel mir,
ich fühlte mich wohl.
Ich schloss als Bester ab.
Ich wurde dann
in dieser Privatschule Fachlehrer.
Ich bin dieser Schule sehr dankbar,
dass ich die Chance erhielt,
dort einen Abschluss zu machen.
Wohin gehst du in die Ferien?
- Nach Italien.
Apulien wird dir bestimmt gefallen.
- Ja.
Davon bin ich überzeugt.
Die Leute dort
werden dich herzlich empfangen.
Etwas "Italianità" als Vorgeschmack
gibt es unmittelbar
neben Luigis Salon,
wo Mama Fragale eine Bar betreibt.
Zu den Stammgästen
gehört seit seiner Pensionierung
auch Papa Fragale.
Heute ist eine Enkelin dabei.
"Tutta la famiglia", die ganze
Familie vereint unter einem Dach.
Etwas, das der Familie
damals in der Schweiz verboten war.
Mit der Erinnerung
kommen Emotionen hoch.
Für mich ...
Was soll ich sagen?
Damals dachten wir,
wir würden nur für zwei,
drei Jahre in die Schweiz kommen.
* Tränenersticktes Murmeln *
Ja, ich werfe der Schweiz vor,
dass sie uns nicht allzu gut
behandelt hat.
Das Gesetz war damals so.
Um die Familie zusammenzuhalten,
habe ich alle hier versteckt,
die Kinder und auch meine Frau.
Ich hätte sie
ja nicht legal mitnehmen können
und wäre neun Monate im Jahr
alleine hier gewesen.
Ich war deprimiert.
Es ging mir schlecht.
Ich war 21, als ich aus Kalabrien
in die Schweiz kam.
Ich hatte meine Familie verlassen,
hatte keine Freunde hier,
war alleine mit Mann
und meinen Kindern.
Er ging morgens aus dem Haus
und kam abends zurück.
Ich hatte nichts Schlechtes getan
und musste mich verstecken. Warum?
Die Kinder konnten nicht
in den Kindergarten, ich nicht raus.
Was sollte dieses Gesetz?
Es war alles in Ordnung.
Mein Mann hatte eine Stelle.
Wir bezahlten die Miete
und die Krankenkasse für ihn.
Ich hätte ein normales Leben
mit den Kindern führen können.
Trotz allem muss ich heute
der Schweiz auch danken.
Sie hat es mir ermöglicht, eine
wunderbare Familie grosszuziehen.
Wir haben alles, dank der Schweiz.
Aber auch ich
habe der Schweiz viel gegeben.
Ich habe
keinen einzigen Tag gestempelt.
Das RAV kenne ich nicht.
Ich habe immer gearbeitet.
Luigi Fragale
unterwegs mit seinen Kindern.
Noch wissen sie nicht,
was ihr Vater einst erleiden musste,
als er in ihrem Alter war.
Vielleicht wird er ihnen
eines Tages davon erzählen.
Unbeschwert sollen sie aufwachsen,
sich draussen bewegen können.
Mein Sohn geht Fussball spielen,
schwimmen ...
Wenn er sich verletzt,
muss er deswegen keine Angst haben.
Kein Kind sollte je
deswegen Angst haben.
* Quietschen *
Ein Märztag im Jahr 1988 im
sankt-gallischen Grenzbahnhof Buchs.
Es ist der erste Extrazug,
der heute aus Jugoslawien kommt.
Nach den Italienern,
den Spaniern und Portugiesen
werden nun
v.a. Menschen aus dem Balkan
als Saisonarbeiter
in die Schweiz geholt,
aus Mazedonien,
einer der ärmsten Gegenden Europas.
35'000 Saisonniers werden in den
nächsten zwei Wochen hier erwartet.
* Stimmengewirr *
Allein an diesem Tag
werden 1'400 Männer
durch die grenzsanitarische
Tuberkulose-Kontrolle geschleust.
Wenn der Arzt
bei der Kontrolle feststellt,
dass die Lunge nicht gut ist,
dann muss die Person am selben Tag
noch zurückreisen.
Dann muss das Herkunftsland zahlen.
Der Klimawechsel z.B.
hat einen Einfluss.
Oder auch das Heimweh.
Wie?
- Das Heimweh.
Wenn jemand Tuberkulose hat
und zudem noch Heimweh,
dann dauert seine Genesung länger,
als wenn es ihm psychisch gut geht.
Susan Weber war in den 60er-Jahren
in der Personalabteilung
eines grossen Bauunternehmens
in Bern tätig,
zuständig für die Saisonniers.
Gelegentlich musste die junge Frau
diese in ihren Baracken aufsuchen.
Katastrophal.
Sie hatten nichts.
Ein Bett,
vielleicht noch
einen geschenkten Stuhl.
Sie mussten sich
in der Küche waschen.
Es gab nur ein Spülbecken.
Es gab kein Bad, keine Dusche.
Nur ein WC,
in einem engen WC-Ding drin.
Und dann mussten sich ...
... gegen acht Personen
alle im selben Spülbecken waschen.
Und die haben tagsüber geschwitzt.
Es war unglaublich.
Ich war richtig schockiert.
Ich musste weinen.
Das ist die Küche.
* Stimmengewirr *
Wie viele Personen kochen hier?
- Acht.
Waschen Sie hier auch die Kleider?
- Ja, alles.
Was noch?
- Sich waschen, rasieren, alles.
Hier sind wir zu viert.
Wie viel zahlen Sie pro Person?
- 60 Fr.
Gibt es eine Putzfrau?
- Nein, wir putzen.
Sind Sie einverstanden
mit diesen Zimmern?
Nein.
Machen Sie nichts?
Was sollen wir tun,
wenn sie uns so halten?
Eine pro Stockwerk?
- Ja.
Gibt es Duschen?
- Nein.
Heisses Wasser?
- Auch nicht.
Haben Sie nie reklamiert?
- Nein.
Warum nicht?
- Da ich erst fünf Monate hier bin.
Sie behandeln uns wie Tiere.
Ich bin mit dem Zimmer
nicht zufrieden.
Sie sehen:
Man muss sich in der Küche waschen.
Sie haben die Toilette gesehen.
Es hat kein Badezimmer.
Wir sind keine Schweine, wir sind
Menschen. Und vier in einem Zimmer.
Während meiner Tätigkeit für
die Gewerkschaft habe ich erreicht,
dass mehrere Baracken geschlossen
und erneuert werden mussten.
Es war einfach nicht akzeptabel,
wie unsere Leute leben mussten.
* Gefühlvolle Musik *
Und gelegentlich
war das Heimweh so gross,
dass ein Saisonnier
seine Kinder verbotenerweise
in die Unterkunft holte,
besonders zur Ferienzeit.
Einmal trafen wir Kinder an,
die sich unter dem Bett versteckten.
Sie hatten grosse Angst und weinten.
Die Mutter sahen wir nicht.
Ich weiss nicht, ob die Kinder
den ganzen Tag alleine dort waren,
bis der Vater nach Hause kam.
Zweimal traf ich solche Kinder an,
einmal auch im Keller.
Da waren es vier Kinder,
die in der Dunkelheit sassen.
Ich habe ...
... wirklich viele Kinder gesehen,
sowohl privat wie auch beruflich.
Es gab Kinder,
die z.B. nicht mehr reden konnten.
Die Sprache war wie eine Gefahr,
denn man sagte ihnen:
"Sprich nicht, weine nicht,
denn sonst kommt die Polizei
und schickt dich zurück nach
Italien, Portugal oder Spanien."
Es gab diejenigen,
die mit Rebellion reagierten
und dann rebellisch wurden.
Es gab Kinder,
die psychosomatische Symptome
entwickelt haben,
wie häufige Bauchschmerzen
ohne sichtbaren Grund,
oder die sehr traurig wurden,
die sehr leise waren.
Und vor allem, das gilt für alle:
Die Kinder hatten keine Möglichkeit
oder nur zu wenig Möglichkeit,
ein kindesgerechtes Leben
zu führen,
eine kindesgerechte Sprache
zu entwickeln.
Denn Kinder lernen auch im Spiel,
lernen mit anderen Kindern.
Und diese Erfahrungen,
die sehr, sehr wichtig
für eine gute Entwicklung sind,
die fehlten ihnen.
Der Schweizer Bevölkerung
waren die Nöte der Fremdarbeiter
kaum bekannt.
Wenn man sieht,
wie diese Menschen in ihren
Herkunftsländern behandelt werden,
dann kann man sagen,
dass sie bei uns in der Schweiz
unseren Verhältnissen entsprechend
sehr gut behandelt werden.
Sie werden viel besser behandelt
als in Deutschland
und noch viel besser
als in Italien.
Ich finde, sie werden
nicht schlecht behandelt.
Ich bin soeben
aus Afrika zurückgekehrt.
Meiner Meinung nach werden sie
mehr als nur gut behandelt.
Dieser Sauhaufen soll ruhig gehen.
Ich denke, dass die Unterkünfte
besser sein könnten.
* Beschwingte Musik *
St. Moritz,
eine schöne Welt für Menschen,
die das Glück haben,
sich diese Welt leisten zu können.
Und ein Heer anderer Menschen,
meist unsichtbar,
sorgt dafür,
dass dieses Bild keine Risse erhält.
Allein 3'000 Portugiesinnen
und Portugiesen
halten im Engadin
die Wirtschaft am Laufen.
Isabel Da Silva ist eine von ihnen.
Sie kam vor über 40 Jahren
als Saisonarbeiterin hierher.
Ein kleines Stück Heimat
findet sie im portugiesischen Laden.
In Portugal
war das Leben damals schwierig.
Ich kam deshalb
mit 17 in die Schweiz.
Ich dachte, eine Saison zu machen
und wieder zu gehen.
Denn es gefiel mir nicht,
in einem Hotel zu arbeiten.
Aber ich kam hierher,
um meinen Eltern helfen zu können,
die unter grossen wirtschaftlichen
Schwierigkeiten litten.
So konnte ich jeden Monat
etwas Geld nach Hause schicken.
Isabel Da Silva,
mit 21 Jahren gebar sie
ihre erste Tochter, Nadia.
Und danach begann der jahrelange,
verzweifelte Kampf einer Mutter.
Da war viel Traurigkeit,
viel Heimweh.
Denn ich musste
meine zweijährige Tochter
bei meiner Mutter zurücklassen.
Das Mädchen nahm das alles wahr,
wollte nicht allein zurückbleiben.
Ich habe
nach allen Möglichkeiten gesucht,
um meine Tochter hier zu haben.
Immer hiess es,
das sei nicht möglich.
Zuerst,
weil ich keine A-Bewilligung hatte.
Ich opferte alles,
um die A-Bewilligung zu bekommen.
Als das Hotel, wo ich arbeitete,
die Saison beendete,
suchte ich eine andere Stelle
in einem ganzjährigen Betrieb,
um 36 Monate in Folge
in der Schweiz zu bleiben
und eine A-Bewilligung zu erhalten.
Als ich dann die Bewilligung hatte,
begann ich erneut zu kämpfen.
Ich ging auf die Gemeindeverwaltung
von St. Moritz
und sagte:
"Ich habe jetzt die A-Bewilligung",
und fragte, ob ich nun
meine Tochter herholen könne,
um sie einzuschulen.
Sie war damals siebenjährig.
Die Gemeinde sagte,
das sei nicht möglich,
denn ich hätte
keine eigene Wohnung.
Ich lebte damals
in der Unterkunft des Hotels.
Also suchte ich nach einer Wohnung,
mietete eine
und ging wieder zur Gemeinde.
Dort rechnete man mir vor, dass ich
nicht genügend verdienen würde,
um meine Tochter zu versorgen.
* Sehnsüchtige Musik *
Ich machte die Rechnung.
Ich arbeitete, mein Mann arbeitete.
Und ich wollte
meine Tochter bei mir haben.
Doch sie sagten: "Nein, unmöglich."
Isabel Da Silva
drohte mit einem Hungerstreik
auf dem Dorfplatz von St. Moritz.
Doch dann schlug sie
einen anderen Weg ein:
zur Bundesverwaltung in Bern.
Meine Tochter war in den Ferien
hier und sie fragte immer:
"Mama,
muss ich nach Portugal zurück?"
Ich sagte:
"Ja. Wie es aussieht, ja",
und das Mädchen weinte.
"Ich will nicht
nach Portugal zurück."
Da war sie acht.
Und ich war verzweifelt
und entschloss mich,
nach Bern zu gehen.
Ich ging einen Gang entlang
und suchte nach dem Namen
der verantwortlichen Person.
Vor der Tür
setzte ich mich auf den Boden.
Ich weinte
und meine Tochter war bei mir.
Die Sekretärin
ging ins Büro und sagte:
"Diese Frau will nicht weggehen.
Es ist besser, sie anzuhören."
Und der Mann war einverstanden.
Er öffnete die Tür und sagte:
"Kommen Sie, was ist Ihr Anliegen?"
Er war sehr freundlich,
sehr verständnisvoll.
Und schliesslich sagte er:
"Gehen Sie nach Hause."
"Aber kann meine Tochter bleiben?"
"In ein, zwei Tagen
erhalten Sie die Antwort."
Und so war es.
Allem Anschein nach hatte er
mit der Gemeinde gesprochen.
Sie riefen mich an und sagten:
"Ja, deine Tochter
kann hierbleiben."
Das war wie ein Wunder,
ein kleines Wunder.
Das war ein riesiges Glück.
Und von diesem Tag an
vergingen die Tage wie Stunden.
Denn vorher litt ich andauernd,
fiel in Depressionen.
Aber als mein Mädchen in die Schule
ging, war ich eine andere Frau.
Ich begann zu leben.
* Melancholische Streichmusik *
Saisonniers,
billige Arbeitskräfte.
Ein Statut regelt ihre Verwendung
und sorgt gleichzeitig dafür,
dass sie der Schweizer Gesellschaft
nicht zu nahe kommen.
Fast 70 Jahre lang,
bis ins Jahr 2002,
als die Personenfreizügigkeit
in Kraft tritt.
* Die Musik verklingt. *
"Wir verlangen die Menschenrechte!"
1970 fordern in Bern aufgebrachte
ausländische Arbeitnehmende
ein Ende der Diskriminierung.
Auch der italienische Staat
ist mit diesem Verlangen
an die Schweizer Regierung gelangt:
ein Ende des Saisonnier-Statuts.
* Aufgebrachte Sprechchöre *
"Schweizer,
würdet ihr es akzeptieren,
das ganze Jahr
ohne eure Familie zu leben?"
"Keine getrennten Familien."
"Ich möchte
bei meinem Vater bleiben!"
Sie gehen gegen die rigiden Regeln
des Saisonnier-Statuts
auf die Strasse.
So dürfen Saisonniers beispielsweise
den Arbeitgeber nicht wechseln,
sind absolut abhängig von diesem.
Doch dass man
aus rechtlosen Saisonniers
nun Gastarbeiter mit
Aufenthaltsbewilligung machen würde,
dies wäre gegen die Interessen
der Bauwirtschaft.
Das Baugewerbe riskiert
eine grössere Abwanderung
von Gastarbeitern
in andere Wirtschaftszweige,
die bessere Arbeitsbedingungen
offerieren können
oder als attraktiver
angesehen werden.
Um diese Abwanderung,
diese Tendenz, auffangen zu können,
wären wahrscheinlich grössere
Lohnzugeständnisse notwendig,
evtl. noch andere Zugeständnisse
in sozialer Hinsicht,
die eine starke Verteuerung
der Bauleistungen
zur Folge haben würden,
und zwar speziell im Hochbau.
* Dynamische Musik *
Saisonarbeiter, jährlich abrufbar,
je nach Wirtschaftslage.
Die gesetzlichen Hürden
sind so hoch gesetzt,
dass es diesen Arbeitern
nur mit Mühe gelingt,
eine Aufenthaltsbewilligung
zu erlangen.
Vier Jahre hintereinander je präzis
neun Monate als Saisonnier.
Dies die Voraussetzung,
um eine Aufenthaltsbewilligung
zu beantragen.
Cécile Bühlmann,
die spätere grüne Nationalrätin,
arbeitete in Luzern auf
der Ausländerberatungsstelle Arbal
und erfuhr von den Tricks,
um Saisonniers eine
Aufenthaltsbewilligung zu verwehren.
Es war eine gängige Praxis.
Wenn ein Arbeitgeber
mit der Leistung eines Arbeiters
sehr zufrieden war
und diesen behalten wollte,
gab er dem Arbeiter im vierten Jahr
nicht mehr neuen Monate.
Und so blieb ihm der Arbeiter
als Saisonnier erhalten.
Denn jene, die vom Saisonnier-
ins Jahres-Statut umwandeln konnten,
wechselten zu besseren Stellen,
zu Jahresstellen.
Sie gingen also den bisherigen
Arbeitgebern verloren,
und diese versuchten,
das zu verhindern,
indem sie ihnen im vierten Jahr
weniger als neun Monate gaben.
Und das Gemeine war, dass es
genau 36 Monate sein mussten.
Eine Kompensation im Folgejahr
war nicht möglich.
Und so schafften es die Leute teils
während acht bis zehn Jahren nicht,
eine Bewilligung zu erhalten.
* In der Ferne läuten Kuhglocken. *
In Obwalden
leitete Josef Gasser 26 Jahre lang
die Fremdenpolizei,
später umbenannt
in "Abteilung für Migration".
Wenn man sich
in der Schweiz etwas umhörte -
ich weiss,
dass es auch Absprachen gab
zwischen Arbeitgebern
und den Migrationsbehörden,
um mit den neun Monaten
etwas zu spielen.
Bei gewissen Sacharbeitern konnte
man zwischen den Zeilen auch lesen,
dass sie nicht unglücklich waren,
wenn es nicht
zu einer Umwandlung kam.
Wenn also ein Arbeitgeber
die neun Monate nicht beantragte,
dann intervenierten sie nicht.
Wenn es nicht
zu einer Umwandlung kam,
hatte man
keine Aufenthaltsbewilligung
und damit kein Anrecht
auf Familiennachzug.
* Knall *
* Fernes Knallen, Applaus *
Es ist das Jahr 1970.
Unter dem Gotthard beginnt der Bau
des längsten Autobahntunnels
der Welt,
ein stolzes Werk
schweizerischer Ingenieurskunst.
Doch die Arbeiter im dunklen Loch
sind grösstenteils Ausländer:
270 von insgesamt 300.
Und was für diese Baustellte gilt,
gilt für die meisten anderen
im Land ebenfalls.
Die Schweiz
wird von Ausländern erbaut.
* Dröhnen, hoher Gesang *
* Stimmungsvolle Musik
zum Gesang setzt ein. *
Rund eine Million Menschen,
meist aus dem armen Süden,
sind an die Bau- und Werkplätze
der Schweiz geholt worden.
Dies entspricht fast 16 %
der damaligen Wohnbevölkerung.
* Gesang und Musik verklingen. *
Überfremdung,
so nennt es dieser Mann,
James Schwarzenbach.
Und er bringt
mit seiner Nationalen Aktion
ein Volksbegehren an die Urne -
1970, im selben Jahr,
in welchem die Ausländer mit dem Bau
des Gotthard-Strassentunnels
begonnen haben.
Die nach ihm
benannte Initiative verlangt,
dass der Ausländeranteil
auf höchstens 10 %
der Wohnbevölkerung
reduziert werden müsse.
300'000 Gastarbeiterinnen
und Gastarbeiter
hätten demnach
die Schweiz zu verlassen.
Das Problem ist sicher
besonders gross geworden,
weil wir nicht
wie Anfang der 60er-Jahre
grösstenteils Norditaliener
bei uns in der Schweiz haben,
sondern heute sind es
grösstenteils Süditaliener.
Hitzige Wortgefechte
in der Öffentlichkeit.
Das ist nicht fair.
Die sind zu faul zum Arbeiten.
Dann machen Sie doch Ihre
Grenzen zu, auch für Touristen.
Wie lange halten wir es
ohne Ausländer aus?
Früher hielten wir es auch aus.
Hast du einen Schweizer Pass?
- Natürlich.
Steht da drauf, dass du ein
Ausländer bist?- Nein, Schweizer.
Im Juni 1970
entscheiden die Schweizer Männer
den Streit an der Urne.
Und dies denkbar knapp.
Acht Kantone
stimmen der Initiative zu.
Schweizweit sind es 46 %
der männlichen Bevölkerung.
* Emotionale Musik *
Im Friedhof von St. Moritz
liegt jener Mann begraben,
der die erste
fremdenfeindliche Partei
im Nachkriegseuropa
gegründet hat.
James Schwarzenbach,
dieses einstige Schreckgespenst
der ausländischen Arbeiterschaft
in der Schweiz.
Seine letzten Jahre
verbrachte er im Engadin.
Fast in Sichtweite
liegt das Hotel Waldhaus in Sils,
wo Schwarzenbach
gelegentlich als Gast einkehrte.
James Schwarzenbach war angemeldet
für ein Abendessen
bei einem unserer Gäste,
den er oft besuchte.
Das war einige Monate
vor der Abstimmung.
Und die Mitarbeiter weigerten sich
tatsächlich, ihn zu bedienen.
Sie gingen zu Rolf Kienberger,
meinem Schwiegervater
und damaligen Hotelleiter,
und sagten zu ihm,
dass sie James Schwarzenbacher
nicht bedienen wollten.
Herr Kienberger erklärte ihnen,
weshalb es sinnvoller ist,
ihn heute Abend genauso freundlich
zu bedienen wie alle anderen Gäste.
Das würde ihn eher beflügeln,
zu sagen,
dass es solch gute Arbeiter auch
in Zukunft in der Schweiz brauche.
Das Fünf-Sterne-Haus war eines
der ersten Engadiner Hotels,
das in den 1970ern Saisonarbeiter
aus Portugal engagierte.
Und dem damaligen Hoteldirektor,
Felix Dietrich,
war die Not dieser Menschen bewusst.
Wir sahen, wie unsere ausländischen
Mitarbeiter und Mitarbeiterinnen,
die als Ehepaar und Saisonniers
hierher kamen,
alles zu Hause zurückgelassen
hatten, aus existentiellen Gründen.
Die Heimat war das eine,
das sie vermissten,
aber ganz stark
vermissten sie ihre Kinder.
Deshalb sagten wir uns, dass wir
eine Lösung finden müssen,
die für alle passt und
die wir auch verantworten können.
So gestattete
Felix Dietrich seinen Saisonniers,
ihre Kinder während
der dreimonatigen Sommerferien
ins Hotel zu holen.
Wir machten etwas, das für uns
in der damaligen Situation
das einzig Richtige
und Menschliche war.
Und wenn jemand zu mir sagte:
"Du machst dich damit strafbar."
"Du könntest dafür
ins Gefängnis kommen."
Dann antwortete ich:
"Das mache ich gern, und ich werde
mir auch keinen Anwalt nehmen,
sondern ich werde persönlich
vor Gericht darzulegen versuchen,
wie wir das gemacht haben."
"Und wer dann noch immer
Schuld an mir findet,
der soll den ersten Stein werfen."
* Heitere Musik *
Gelegentlich
kehrt Nadia ins Engadin zurück.
Heute lebt die ältere
der zwei Töchter von Isabel Da Silva
mit ihrer Familie im Unterland.
Bei ihren Besuchen erinnert sie sich
an den Kampf ihrer Mutter.
Ja, sie musste sehr dafür kämpfen,
dass ich hierher kommen durfte.
Es war ungewiss.
Ich war
während den Sommerferien hier -
in Portugal gibt es drei Monate
Schulferien im Sommer.
Und dann kam der Entscheid -
ich glaube, er kam wenige Tage,
bevor ich wieder
hätte abreisen müssen.
Und dann hiess es,
ich dürfe in der Schweiz bleiben.
Das war der glücklichste Tag
in meinem jungen Leben.
"Ich darf
mit meinen Eltern zusammen sein."
Das bedeutete mir alles.
Isabel Da Silva
ist im Engadin geblieben,
wo sie 1978 ein neues Leben begann,
17-jährig als Zimmermädchen,
Monatslohn: 600 Fr.
Der jahrelange Kampf um ihre Tochter
hat sie nicht verbittert.
Ich bin sehr glücklich.
Ich habe meine Kinder hier,
meine Enkel.
Die Schweiz
ist meine zweite Heimat geworden.
Und ich bin dankbar dafür, dass sie
mir diese Möglichkeit gegeben hat.
Ich weiss nicht, vielleicht würde
ich die Schweiz vermissen,
wenn ich nach Portugal zurückginge.
Untertitelung: Sucevic Solutions
im Auftrag von SWISS TXT - 2023